imagine our houses without a fence or
boundary wall
this would make our properly easy
accessible to trespassers
and robbers and place our homes at great
risk
right hence fencing our property helps
safeguard it
and keeps trespassers at bay similarly
imagine our computers and networks
without protection
this would increase the probability of
hackers infiltrating our networks
to overcome this challenge just like how
boundary walls protect our houses a
virtual wall helps safeguard
and secure our devices from intruders
and such a wall is known as a firewall
firewalls are security devices that
filter the incoming
and outgoing traffic within a private
network
for example if you were to visit your
friend who lives in a gated community
you would first take permission from the
security guard the security guard would
check with your friend
if you should be allowed to entry or not
if all is well
your access is granted on the other hand
the security guard would not grant
permission to a trespasser
looking to enter the same premises here
the entry access depends solely on your
friend
the resident's discretion the role of
the security guard in this case
is similar to that of a firewall the
firewall works like a gatekeeper at your
computer's entry point
which only welcomes incoming traffic
that it has been configured to accept
firewalls filter the network traffic
within your network and
analyzes which traffic should be allowed
or restricted
based on a set of rules in order to spot
and prevent cyber attacks
your computer communicates with the
internet in the form of network packets
that hold details like the source
address
destination address and information
these network packets
enter your computer through ports the
firewall works on a set of rules based
on the details of these network packets
like their source address a destination
address content
and port numbers only trusted traffic
sources
or ip addresses are allowed to enter
your network
when you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers
infiltrating your network this is when a
firewall comes to your rescue
by acting as a barrier between your
computer and the internet
the firewall rejects the malicious data
packet and thus
protects your network from hackers on
the other hand
traffic from trusted websites is allowed
access to your network
this way the firewall carries out quick
assessments to detect malware and other
suspicious activities
thereby protecting your network from
being susceptible to a cyber attack
firewalls can either be hardware or
software
software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer
this is also called a host firewall
meanwhile
hardware firewalls are equipments that
are established between the gateway
and your network linksys routers are a
good example of a hardware firewall
besides this there are other types of
firewalls designed based on their
traffic filtering methods
structure and functionality the firewall
that compares each outgoing and incoming
network packet
to a set of established rules such as
the allowed ip addresses
ip protocols port number and other
aspects of the packet
is known as a packet filtering firewall
if the incoming network traffic is not
per the predefined rules
that traffic is blocked a variant of the
packet filtering firewall
is the stateful inspection firewall
these types of firewalls not only
examine each network packet
but also checks whether or not that
network packet is part of an established
network connection
such firewalls are also referred to as
dynamic packet filtering firewalls
our next type of firewall is called a
proxy firewall
this draws close comparison to how you
give proxy attendance for a friend
like how you take the authority to
represent your friend the proxy firewall
pretends to be you
and interacts with the internet they
come between you and the internet
and thereby prevents direct connections
this protects your device's identity
and keeps the network safe from
potential attacks
only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you
they are also known as application level
gateway the firewall can spot malicious
actions and block your computer from
receiving data packets from harmful
sources
in addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institutions
and offices to restrict users access to
certain websites or applications
it is used to avoid access to
unauthorized content
so here's a question for you which
firewall is also known as
application level gateway a proxy
firewalls
b stateful inspection firewalls c
packet filtering firewalls d dynamic
packet filtering firewalls
do give it a thought and leave your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
cyber crimes are today making headlines
every day
and individuals and companies must do
everything possible to secure their
information
hence using security devices that help
safeguard our networks from falling prey
to deadly cyber attacks
is the need of the hour we hope you
enjoyed this video if you did a thumbs
up would be really appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell icon for
more on the latest technologies and
trends
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
[Music]